in newark new jersey right now
people have erected a 700 pound
statue of george floyd
george there is now a monument and a
memorial
to george floyd people are taking photos
with it like he's a hero like he's a
saint
george floyd was an unreformed career
criminal
who robbed pregnant women at gunpoint he
held a gun to a pregnant woman
while his buddies robbed her he died
while resisting arrest for committing
another crime it's not even like look
saint paul was a murderer people turned
their lives around
this guy didn't he was killed
under these dubious circumstances and in
a very
very problematic trial where you had
political pressure all the way up to the
president of the united states and
threats of riots from from congressmen
eventually that they convicted him of
murder but i
i suspect they're going to have quite a
lot to talk about on the appeal
but even so sure dubious circumstances
no question about it lots of questions
the whole reason george floyd was on the
ground is because he asked to be taken
out of the cop car
why did he ask to be taken out of the
cop car unclear he was obviously very
high on drugs at the time
but even the claim that the cop
callously refused to
to get off of him off of his neck and
then we learned it was actually also his
shoulders
when he said i can't breathe is because
he was saying i can't breathe before the
cop ever really even touched him
this i'm not saying that
we're we know that this was a justified
arrest we know exactly how he died we
really don't even though the court ruled
we know that there was a lot of pressure
on that court
a lot of irregularities but even so
let's let's say it was a totally
unjustified killing
let's say the guy was murdered you erect
a statue of an unreformed criminal
only you only do that in a culture
that values grievance
and racial resentment over
virtue sanctity holiness patriotism
courage
all of these sorts of things absolutely
insane but it's why it's happening now
this is the other point i make on the
juneteenth national holiday
if this is really just oh it's a great
thing we're just celebrating this
holiday that's it's been around for
forever it's been around for 100 years i
mean no one's ever heard of it but no
it's been around for so long and
what you never heard of juneteenth yeah
okay
why now why is there this big push
right now do you think it has to do with
remembering the glories of the union
troops and abraham lincoln
or do you think it has more to do with
the
racial resentment narrative that has
cropped up and that has actually
exploded literally onto the streets
of our country burning down city after
city
notably during the blm riots of 2020.
what do you think it's more about
what do you think it's more about
actually i know what it's about because
people say
why are holidays created columbus day
was created
in part for the 400th anniversary of the
great the great explorer
in part because italians the previous
year had been the victims of the largest
mass lynching in american history so it
was in part
to seem to make amends to italians and i
suspect that's what's going on here it's
to make amends
to black people in america
what what will this accomplish what will
it do what is the amend specifically for
i suspect it's not a whole lot has
changed in the last
several decades i suspect what it's for
is this canard
of the epidemic of systemic white racism
and the cops and the killers and the
white supremacy is the greatest threat
to america whatever merrick garland told
us
it's a it's a false narrative that's
being pushed
and republicans sadly going along with
it
hey i'm glad you like that video there's
a whole show though there's a whole
episode
that you could watch here on youtube
subscribe ring the bell you'll get the
notifications or
on apple podcast spotify google play
stitcher google mail
aim zanga live i don't know it's all
over the place
the michael knowles show subscribe leave
a five star review we'll see you there